[Music]
so
how i accidentally
became the biggest chess streamer of all
time me
how is that possible
[Laughter]
oh please don't hurt me
oh my god
[Music]
no
i am not a chess streamer i don't know
what i'm doing
i was just trying to draw a line but
accidentally dragged that
am i dead
we can kill him
no what
wait what
i want a refund
can i stop my wife
[Music]
in as much cash as you can carry you can
keep i don't care if you put in your
pockets and your hoodie and your pants
and your shoes you know i still need to
whip out my camera and
put on
a smile
to get my picture taken paul champs
competitor here
[Music]
hey guys welcome to thanks thanks for
the host
yeah moving the pawn out two squares hey
yo this move here is too rare he got the
two pawns out there as friends yeah
night came around yo we ready to end oh
my god the queen making moves already
yeah pull the queen out yo this dude is
heavy yeah and y'all know knights move
at the angle you're stepping up to mack
then you're straight
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome everybody it's
day three of pogchamps 4 with me the one
and only gotham chess levy rosman it's
it's it's been a minute since we did a
show together welcome in man
thank you i am so pumped um
any chess commentary is good but
pogchamps commentary is the best and
danny wrench on top of that
i i don't think my date can be any
better danny just wanted
danny i'm i'm pumped for it man and uh
let's let's do the thing we do at the
top of the show remind the very few
people who are hiding under a rock and
and maybe not following all the podcamps
action who's playing in this particular
uh leg leg of pog champs are 16
participants full of faces from all
around mainly the twitch streaming
community with uh
with well a lot of new faces uh this
this this round levy and anybody stand
out to you this is your first uh first
commentary session for pogchamps for
anyone you're you're excited to see in
in this event
yeah i'm always curious about who who
are the players who kind of start
quietly and then all of a sudden become
absolute killers right
like last time it was it was benji uh
and obviously sardocia is now like an
1800 level player i mean it's absolutely
insane
um so be better than me so i think so
to be honest yeah this guy is like
probably going to become a master level
player
especially with the degree of obsession
that he has with the game healthy
obsession or maybe not but
i know that croakies is like already
popping off he's like 1200
a lot of these players have a lot of
experience whether they're one-time
podcamps participants or participants in
a lot of these events i mean ludwig has
played
every chess.com event it feels like so
he
he might be a
top candidate to win this whole thing
yeah it's going to be crazy down the
stretch obviously i did everything i
could yesterday to try to get jimmy to
be able to beat love and we'll talk
about that later but we do have one one
piece of news uh astute observers we'll
see we have a new face there in our
row of 16 participants nick a30 uh nick
e 30 nick a 30. i guess i probably
should have known how to say that but
lol um first first uh gaff moment of the
day he has stepped in for connor eats
pants who uh needed to step away from
the event so
nick is super pumped to be joining the
field it's funny he sent a tweet out a
few days ago after twitch rivals on
thursday begging to be in pogchamps and
i went into the dms with him levy and
was like hey man that's not possible we
got 16 people you you you can't play
this time maybe pogchamps five but uh as
fate would have it and then he
and then he called someone he knew and
conor had to withdraw and more connor
yeah that was a
one in 16 chance it was going to be him
but yeah important no i thought his
people obviously hope no his people
called conor's people and apparently
they worked out a deal so but anyway no
we're super excited to have nick i think
his first match is tomorrow but we'll
update everyone on the schedule right
now we gotta update everyone on what
happened yesterday we all know you can
learn and earn with coinbase and so
let's see what we learned from day two
this is our coinbase recap of of the
pogchamps action from yesterday
why would you check my king
what do you get from contact don't see
now the checkmate i'm pretty sure fondy
sees it
you don't really get anything
yeah okay i guess you're there now i
guess
that will only just now realize
[Music]
i can push in it's like a chest puzzle
it would indeed be like a chess puzzle a
checkmate puzzle
yup made in two
[Music]
a clean win
oh wait th this is actually wait
what's up with the king and indeed
wicked checkmate
that was a really cool checkmate
the king coming closer and he knows it
oh he's
[Laughter]
i can't believe i just beat him oh my
gosh
yes
oh my gosh none of you none of you
thought i was gonna beat this man none
of you look at that that is right oh my
gosh
oh my god did anyone just see what i
just did yes there's a two second
increments just three minutes plus two
seconds increment he has now collected a
lot of time went all the way up 10
minutes
there we go nice
that was such an impressive match
what did i do wrong what a relief for
ludwig
but it looks so relieved that was
the
hardest chess game i have ever played in
my life if you two make it to the same
bracket of the tournament you can still
face each other in the championship
bracket someone needs to beat him
just half trained and paid
his next opponent
come on please send him the phone notes
oh yeah i got it right here you just
post them on twitter all right they get
accessible
dm to go [__] off
now i'm not going to lie i deserve that
levy two hours before the the match
yesterday all me and jimmy were doing
was going over how to beat lovely
scandinavian what has been your
experience i mean obviously you've had
that as as a coach for pogchamps in our
fourth edition have you ever been
watching and been like sitting there
like oh my gosh i'm literally going to
effect and win this game for for the guy
that i just worked with
uh so last pogchamps mr beast and i did
that uh before his he had a matchup with
somebody i don't know if you remember
but i think he he played
an opening that we had just looked at
prior i think it might have been against
ludwig again wasn't it or maybe it
wasn't
i'm thinking it might have been yeah
yeah but but i don't remember 100
and i was getting really pumped but the
problem is dude like if you're 6 700 the
opening is absolutely meaningless you
know you can get like to the end
and you have to win the game he still
won the game which is super impressive
and
uh yeah ludwig had that mini disaster
toward the end so just make sure you're
not stalemating your opponent
but
all that game showed me danny is that
you can be
massive you can be accomplished you can
seem like you are at the top of the
world and yet the victory in a chess
game that's that's all that matters it
feels so good it's all that matters the
endorphins of a winning the endorphins
of winning a chess game we saw mr
beast's reaction but i won't repeat the
explicitives that lubwig threw at me i
said you're welcome lud i just showed
you that you need to mix up your
openings a little bit me and jimmy jimmy
hasn't played chess in six months and he
just he just beat you so you're welcome
ludwig anyway he didn't take it that way
so all right well before before we get
into today's pairings i want to remind
everybody that a big part of what we're
doing here is
for the community uh it is for raising
raising awareness raising money for rise
above the disorder and their cause to
remove the two greatest barriers
to for people accessing mental health
care which is access and affordability
uh they start it was started by world of
warcraft guild leader in 2013 rise above
the disorder helps thousands tens of
thousands of people from around the
world receive mental health care free of
charge it's a super important cause um
on day one we actually had an amazing uh
shout out by the one and only levy
rosman oh he's on the show today so that
was that was really appreciated and
uh everyone can go to go.just.com
rad to make a donation uh you can use
the command donate we are matching up to
a hundred thousand dollars and today
look at that okay the 1300 number we got
to get to 2k today guys i know that the
show is just getting going or pogchamps
versus uh i am christina and then puns
versus rubius
your thoughts levy
i'm excited man um this is a for me
personally a field of three uh
completely new individuals so
uh i have no idea what to expect i know
that croakies has been like working hard
and like i said he's like a sleeper to
win this thing it's curious to know
how much uh rubius has also improved
because uh anna rudolph is like
recording offline lessons for him uh
christine is brand new sorry
yeah yeah yeah oh no i i thought you
were uh
i thought i said something wrong i heard
your voice so i got scared um i'm like i
feel like a kid and i never i would
never be scared i'm i'm we're we're this
is a safe place levy no one's watching
us this is just me and you
that says a lot about the twitch
shows.com channel but um no i mean
actually the player i know the least
about in this field is is is puns so i
yeah i don't i don't even know how
strong puns how strong is puns he played
he played in the block champs event that
the botest sisters uh hosted a little
bit ago and um
i'm curious to i know he's been doing
some lessons i think you highlighted it
right i mean croakies is the guy right
now that people are circling as as this
you know this events whatever you want
to call it uh you know hafu or sardo she
is all in it was funny he when he found
out on on his stream like a week and a
half ago
when he found out oh man the price is
actually 20k he's like wow okay wait a
second like he was like i'm gonna grind
here and get it um so i think it's gonna
be a tough match up there for christine
um christina um but puns rubios i bet is
going to be uh pretty close to a coin
flip so uh speaking of coins that you
flip i hear that coinbase is coming out
with a flippable coin just kidding
that's not actually happening but um you
can you can go to uh coinbase.com
chess and get five dollars in bitcoin
just for signing up like i said on day
one that's real money just for being a
real person
and um it doesn't get much better than
that so go to
coinbase.com yes today uh whether you're
brand new to crypto or an experienced
trader they are the place to be and uh
you should you should do that as we go
to a break don't go anywhere the first
moves of day three pogchamps four
presented by coinbase will be on the
board when we return
thing again ma'am idiot edot
hi guys is twice one
look like a goddamn phil
as i said it's the same message twice or
so i'm ready to come on let's go
come on
on the second occasion and only on the
second occasion i hit it with the old
sorry caps lock
the first time i just let the gap stay
and just let it let it fester a little
bit you know
find out how they wanted to handle that
one
i think it's about start ladies and
gentlemen i'll see you on the other side
i need to close my chat
goodbye and good night
chat closed
preparations complete
chess match ready
one zero currently playing for two let's
go
anybody else hungry
i could do with a banana
[Music]
is that too loud guys
hopefully it's fine i need the banging
beats you know to maintain my thought
process
[Music]
should be fine
i require thought all right here we go
okay that's not start it i thought that
very cool
before we jump in to follow all the
games let's remind everybody where they
can follow us
uh you can use all the different
commands uh to get more information
especially the command discord if you
haven't joined our discord community
i'll remind you of more reasons you want
to do that because of our presenting
sponsor coinbase later but uh hit us up
everywhere else that chess exists online
going online people know about it it's
chess
speaking of things that go online our
team made a uh
what
i was going to say once you're done with
that you can also you know type in
gotham chests it's like the same word
just saying words same words yeah just
just
chess at gotham chess everywhere that
gotham chess exists is where you'll find
levy rosman
um and uh
we we had to show this one of the big
things that happened yesterday levi you
mentioned ludwig as you know many
people's eyes may be the favorite the
most experienced pogger
but boxbox has been pretty bummed
because robert hess has pretty much
fully committed to coaching ludwig now
and boxbox was uh he let it be known on
camera he's not happy about that
um anyway wait why was was robert uh
coaching boxbox he was in the first pog
champs back in june of 2020 many
lifetimes ago well you know robert was
you know dating two pogchamps
participants at the same time and
decided to commit fully to ludwig
what can you do boxbox went back to uh
to doing uh what he usually does which i
believe is
yeah league of legends i'm sorry we got
to talk about format right or are we
just getting into the game and we'll
talk about the format the players are
split into four different groups you all
know that three points for an outright
win two points for a win in a tiebreaker
and one point for a loss in a tiebreaker
obviously zero for losing both games the
players play two games always you flip
colors and go again with the ten minute
plus five second increment and remember
that even players who might start off on
the wrong foot there's a consolation
bracket with pretty decent prizes and
that's one of the fun things about the
event is you see people continuing to
get better and in the end winning the
consolation barrack it kind of feels
like winning the whole thing i mean to
me
if i was the best of the losers levy
that might be the greatest thing i've
ever accomplished
what do you mean if you were i thought
that was like long decided
[Laughter]
that wasn't even like
as i was saying it
i
a lot of things went through my i didn't
even mean that in an ins i didn't mean
to even call you a loser just you
self-roast so much that i just thought
that it would make sense danny i'm sorry
that that i didn't i wasn't trying to
even roast that came out way worse than
i intended i'm very sorry um if you'd
like to end the show preemptively um
that was great um
well uh i made a joke on the on the
twitch rivals show that sardoche might
be a better chess player than me and
amman immediately said yeah actually
i'll take that bet i was like well
thanks simon you know have a lot of
faith in me um danny
you have gm talent all right you just
decided to run the best thing that ever
happened to chess online okay i
appreciate that so you know you could
have been a gm but well why they don't
get paid you saw mine's still on twitter
you know so we're here we're here doing
pog champs so uh it's just one letter
danny it's just one letter difference it
is that doesn't matter um
and uh and
it you know i comes before g in the
alphabet does it wait do i even know my
alphabet oh the game started no danny it
definitely does not okay
um
sorry about that i'm going to uh follow
the players real quick because you and i
are just having a good time um here we
go we got a queen's gambit on the board
from croakies
yup
um
do we know ooh so is this a accidental
uh
renaissance right here this uh this this
baltic defense or is this just
improvisation because this is a very
tricky opening but only if black is well
prepared yeah i'm gonna guess it's
improvisation because i think a lot of
the players uh learning learning to
london with white
um
and uh despite my my best efforts to to
advise against that i think a lot of the
players then face the queen's pawn as
black and as they're learning the game
they're you know they're playing the
similar developing move in the london
and the difference here everyone is of
course
white can take d5 and probably have a
big center advantage although crooked
chooses not to do that he plays knight
f3 that's actually i was gonna say a lot
of people who learn the queen's gambit
don't realize the point of the c4 move
is to challenge the pawn and like to
take it if it cannot be recaptured with
a pawn because then you win a bunch of
time so
uh we've seen knight f6 a lot in pog
champs on move two not bishop f5 yeah it
would be a similar thing and we'll we'll
highlight that because part of that we
do this so we can all get better at
chess it really is an instructive point
that a lot of players who even improve
in other areas forget this basic point
which is the whole point of the queen's
gambit is that when you take it i'm
going to get two pawns in the center so
if you let me take this pawn for anybody
but upon recapturing you're giving me
that advantage and that's just a very
good instructive thing to know whoa
christine and he
took on b1
she is
all in with the aggressive tactics i
like it i mean normally you don't
take an undeveloped piece but let's see
if we can listen and see what she's
talking about she's streaming right now
mm-hmm
i think she said she didn't like
something
was
[Music]
whether she should move it to e6 or e5
i can be the translator i can't speak
spanish like as well as i used to but i
can still understand it
so you could you could tell me she's
saying a lot of different things and i
would be on board um my wife actually
speaks fluent spanish um but
that hasn't really ever come up in our
marriage as a random note so you know
she hasn't taught the kids to like talk
with her in spanish about you
that's a good idea well our oldest is
actually taking spanish so they do
sometimes converse and i just you know
do what i do most the time just not pay
attention to anybody around the house um
anyway bishop g5 played and uh
okay
if black played the move 94 this would
be a good move taking advantage of the
fact that the knight isn't pinned yet
but that might be a hard move uh to find
it's an aggressive move
for christina to find um
i'm just gonna call her christine is
that okay because christina knee sounds
like a tongue twister
i think it's cristinini
i think
but you know what i'm too afraid of
like just laying that down as a claim
and being completely wrong but
politicians seem to do it pretty well
but i'm too scared uh yeah i think it's
christinini but okay christine
i'm gonna say it the way you just said
it levy rosman has dubbed the proper
pronunciation um okay croakies is
obsessed with the catalan which on the
one hand is kind of interesting um
because it's it's not something we've
seen in many podcamps and i had one
lesson with him
um
and uh
kinda kind of advised it might not be
necessary to maybe do a traditional
queen's gamut but he likes it he loves
fee encountering the bishops he also
plays the dragon as black against e4 so
he's a he's a fian kettle girl and we
are in a fian kettle world
yes i like g3 bishop g2 very much it
also seems to be the meta at the super
gm level nowadays yeah uh
i very much have fallen in love with
putting my bishops on g2 and g7 in
virtually any opening that i'm playing
at this point so uh by the way we should
probably take a look at his screen ah
he just clicked off but he had so many
arrows up and it's like move six it was
very interesting
let's see we'll listen in and enjoy the
sweet sounds of a uh english welsh
accent
[Music]
just vibe
yeah
that's okay
[Music]
actually let's our knight out right
which is pretty good
unless i'm missing something
that like sorry that's our best shot
which is pretty good
[Music]
i mean this this knight is always going
to a square like that or that
e5
d2
anyway
[Music]
right now
are saying is the accent sounds scottish
i don't know if i agree with that
[Music]
sorry danny can't i can't talk i'm
listening to good music right now
the celtic this is like celtic and
techno had a baby and then a red bearded
man came so she can take this pawn but
um
yeah that's uh i feel like that's how
all of us wish we can play chess just
hang out some some good beats some good
vapes and uh
just
and he's having a good time i wonder
what flavor the vape is you know that's
what i'm interested i'm not interested
in
in the chest anymore we'll ask him that
in the interview because we got to ask
him something and that'll be that'll be
a great question um
the uh
the flake what's the flavor flav okay e3
is played
now this will be interesting whether
croakies commits the bishop to the
diagonal over here rather than the
fianchetto diagonal
um
i will say this christine uh
i'll say chris she goes by chris as well
chris is new to the game
and so this is a great start for her
right i think we all know she's the
underdog here croakies is grinding no
denying that so i think we should
point out the uh the positive points of
how she's approached the opening she's
developed she's castled
um
and if she gets aggressive in the center
black arguably is doing just fine i mean
you could even consider taking this pawn
here
yeah i'm
sort of unless i'm seeing that
incorrectly the machine thinks that
white is slightly better
i guess it's because the bishop on g2 is
better than the knight on c6 but this is
not the aim chess rapid this is uh yeah
this is pogchamps four so yeah i think
objectively it's
very close to equal uh but having said
that the game could be over in the next
five moves i mean someone could
that's
i agree with the way you said that
though that the engine says why it's
better but i felt like you were kind of
saying from a practical point of view if
black started playing aggressive opening
moves this is not you know the champions
chess tour this is a
champs event and i actually feel like
her position is pretty good if she if
she played what what are the most
natural kind of moves she should be
considering right now to take the pawns
and maybe open the center while while
croakies hasn't castled yet
yeah actually pawn takes c4 is
completely free so
at least from my vantage point and then
maybe the machine gives some advantage
to white because of the triple pawns but
yeah give me quadruple pawns in
pogchamps for i mean i i'm not scared no
this is this is
i watch complex
video one time by gotham chess have you
ever heard of gotham chess levy rosman
uh yeah uh when i first started playing
yeah i watched some of his basics um
can't stand the guy but he makes really
good content so you know it's kind of a
lovely content for beginners but he
talked to me about double pawns one time
and we'll see if that becomes an issue
here
97 plate allows the double pawns and
we'll see what chris is thinking about
i do not know what was just said i'm
sorry
my translation skills end when slang
begins
um
[Music]
yup
do it yeah
she doesn't want to open her king but
you have to otherwise you're just losing
too much oh no no no
no no take the bishop
you know they they properly learn and
value king safety
but they should okay very good that was
actually that was actually a positive
trait for her right there
yeah she
she she deflected his queen off of the
diagonal so he couldn't come to see oh
my god
that was a doze
yeah and you heard her saying reina like
she was talking about the queen and and
so she was talking about the queen
coming out
and we'll show what levy was just saying
because he's totally right that she saw
this
and she was worried about this and even
though maybe the check isn't that great
like the recognition of that was
actually
super good
and so she takes here to deflect the
queen and then takes back
even if even if it wasn't for queen g4
trading pieces before your king becomes
open is already a very good idea so
bravo she's on track and now the
position's opening up
yeah that was awesome the whole thought
process there made sense uh as you get
better at the game
you can kind of evaluate whether you
have to be afraid of certain moves or
not
um actually that decision that she just
made made me go check
when she actually started playing chess
she's played like less than 100 rapid
games and a chunk of those games were
back in march which was the heyday of
pogchamps 3. so yeah yeah i mean she
maybe played 50 games
and solid logic
anna reached out to me um
like a month and a half ago um chris was
actually one of the first people
seriously interested and
it was awesome she's one of the top 10
streamers in spain and spanish
spanish-speaking streamers and she uh
she said like you said she's been
playing chess since
since probably pogchamps three kind of
had a lot of people
get more interested in the game um
yeah now now is the difficult part
because as the game goes on
uh the player with the higher rating
will be able to make certain trades a
little bit better and then
you know activate their pieces a little
bit better and that pawn on f6 is just
brutal
rippling wow b5 is good move though
defines a great move i i think if
maybe the only other better move might
have been a move like knight d6 to block
off the rook and guard the pawn but
either way white is better and b5 was it
was a great great idea
here comes the rook down to d7 that's
what i was worried about but
as long as we don't get a back rank mate
right let's get some end game technique
no background
i think it's pretty likely i i can
expect like a rook d8 rook d1 and then
the black king is just stranded on g8
but if she then plays h6 i mean
if she recognizes
she's playing great i mean rook c8
defends the pawn obviously bishop b7
and bishop h3 are actually both actually
both pretty nasty moves here for
croakies um
he's about to play bishop b7
yeah
you got him
am i
rolling through
or am i about to hop
into a nightclub
nightclub
nightclub okay
i was gonna say because if there was a
soundtrack just playing like from you
know she comes across
again maybe holding hands with a with a
bearded a bearded redheaded man like
like trophies i might hear this in the
background
is that weird
no
i think i think music music allows you
to have your own interpretation and your
own vision and
you know you add the vape anything is
possible and it's possible it is a good
move the problem is that white is very
safe
okay
okay okay okay okay okay
taking his time
yeah this guy's a grinder um we talked
about box box
i don't know man i'm not scared maybe i
should be
at the top of the show oh whoa
if she takes that pawn there
up she did it
[Music]
oh no
double reaction here we go
i want to cry
let's get to 2k today everybody we're
raising money for charity rad rise above
the disorder
supports mental health uh
this this was um a game that
kind of went the way we expected levy
obviously croakies is a beast right now
um but i i actually feel like chris
played super well there i mean i was i
was i was impressed consolation bracket
here we come
yep i think uh i think she's got she's
got plenty of potential it's just
important not to get discouraged because
it's it's just a total mystery once you
get out into a middle game and he just
seemed experienced and kind of knew what
to do and knew the threat and um
you know she said i want to cry but she
has another game to go so
we've seen upsets happen already i think
we're going to go for a short break yeah
and then we'll be back with the second
game yeah don't don't cry don't cry for
christina just yet luckily she has a
coach like anna rudolph who will stay
super positive with her and all right
we're going to be back in just a few
moments with game two between croakies
and i am christina park champs four
presented by coinbase returns in a few
as i said i don't normally do that but
[Music]
just because if i get the chance to take
there it would open up the pawns but i
mean i guess it's an inaccuracy just
because
it's never gonna work right
they just push the pawn like that
the big two
all right this has to be a skip to man
that song's trash
at least it's not for it's not the song
for right now man
i need
to remain calm
no emotional explosions
maybe we can try the techno stuff again
or drop drum let's do a drum and bass
playlist
well a little bit of dnb
right now we're playing as the black
pieces though
and i have no idea what her opinions are
so please please just play if e5 or
please play e4 or d4
no
move one knight or anything like that
i'm only prepared i literally only have
preparation for two opening moves
all right
let's start with the knight f3 and um
i'm batman gg
gg
probably should not be sharing that
knowledge with any spies in the chat but
that's okay i've got four days till my
next game
i'll be ready for the spooky openings
[Music]
i will say one thing chat though
after our awful games earlier today i
was able to think a little bit
in that match
i got my brain above level zero which is
honestly progress over the rest of our
game
pogchamps 4 is presented by coinbase
whether you're looking to make your
first crypto purchase or you're an
experienced trader coinbase has you
covered earn crypto by learning about
crypto with coinbase earn power up your
trading with coinbase's advanced
features get exclusive rewards when you
spend with coinbase card and much more
learn more at coinbase.com
chess
man can i can i just say i don't know
that coinbase has ever looked sexier our
video team i'm going to give a shameless
plug to the chess.com video team for
making that look amazing and makes me
want to go
learn and earn over on coybase.com
obviously like we said you can go to
coinbase.com chess get five dollars in
bitcoin when you sign up five dollars in
bitcoin is actually a lot of bitcoin
from what i hear these days levy do you
levy do you crypto
hell yeah crypto you come on coinbase
right now maybe yeah
i don't i would show the chat but then i
would leak my portfolio balance and i
might lose a few subscribers so yeah of
course chat so at the break i just
literally went to eternal.gg use the
company credit card don't zoom in on
that don't tell the company either
bought myself a little pre-order
pogchamps for uh collectible i legit did
that that's a break um and um i have no
idea what it's in for but like i said
the eternal dg looks like looks really
looks really cool so i did it and i'm
super pumped for uh for my pack um
listen clean bass um
uh just one more thing before we start
like you know blending all the all the
sponsor plugs um yeah i mean
crypto uh was always like totally
fascinating i was i was around as they
begin the second game i was around in
the world of crypto when like circle was
a thing and then coinbase took over and
they've had like some bumps and and
bruises but man they are really the
industry
yeah standard they seem to be like
awesome and they they really just figure
out any problems and so
love them and i can confirm that that
wasn't just like a made-up plug by levi
he was literally using the coinbase app
at the break and uh
so if you're not using coinbase to uh to
engage and trade your crypto you're
you're uh you're making a mistake also i
was just informed that i'm not the only
one who bought a pre-order pack of the
pog champs for collectibles apparently
they've already sold 10k and the
pre-orders have been live for like
half an hour so a lot of people are
jumping in line to get their collectible
moments here for pog champs for and uh
that's cool good for them like th that
whole that whole sponsor shout out
became one so we love them both thank
you to both coinbase and eternal for
your support of the event
um we have bishop on b5 levy there is a
bishop on b5 there is a bishop on i5
i uh i thought there was maybe a knight
on f3 in the night on c6 and i thought
we were going for the rossolimo
variation very very common but um
this is the expedited russell emote this
is the
is that an orange highlight dude did you
know you could you do that on plano here
look what you can do you hold alt you
can hold control you can hold shift i
can do that with arrows
i can do it with arrows
i can do
anything i want now it's like visual oh
you know what else i can do with levi
have you seen this
have you ever heard uh
have you ever heard of levy rosman
gotham chess did you know that he is now
a face on chess.com's chessboard
i i did not
what's your favorite my gun
what's your favorite square oh what's my
oh what's my favorite square um um um um
um
i i didn't prepare for this interview c6
i guess c6 which would you say c6 c6
yeah oh the carol khan square so i was
actually esp there i was psychically in
tune already
everyone knows my favorite square the om
the omg omg spot over here
that is crazy
wow
yeah you can do that too all you got to
do is hold the letter e over the
chessboard
and you can do anything you want also is
that is that is that for premium members
or is that for anybody
um
honestly i don't even know these days
what it is boom goes the dynamite on c4
damn all right well if it's for premium
members there's my link in the chat you
know what to do
get all these features
if you are going to go premium right now
do it via the gotham chest link send
send your affiliate support back to god
that was hilarious yes sir yes sir oh by
the way bad news i actually oh bad news
they're for any they're for anyone so
you don't need to go premium with gotham
chest to have access sorry
yes
uh well this was not a pre-planned uh ad
routine otherwise it would have been
absolutely genius um you see i'm still a
boomer i'm still on chess.com live yeah
and they warned me today that you guys
are
by the end of the year it's gonna be
done you know i feel like the guy who
still has the verizon flip phone dude
and uh
hey
i'm the reason it still exists you're
talking to the number one boomer if this
boomer wasn't at the helm of the chess
ship they would have got rid of live a
long time ago and i'm like no it's not
ready there's so full disclosure
the play server is actually still in
beta a little bit but
90 of our users are already using the
new play in fact most of the people who
use live levy are guys like us because
we've already been using it for years so
yep it's always the title players
keeping the rest of society trying to um
you know advance and leave it to chess
players to hold hold the world back huh
oh absolutely by the way we got like a
great game on this yeah this is
fantastic right here
um i'm i'm proud of them
yeah so uh
jokes aside we started with this this
fun bishop b5 idea which is is a good
developing move like levi said it's a
rosso limo and that's kind of what we
got an awkward transposition into a
rossolimo bishop g4 is a a good
developing move but
chris just gets the bishop pair and now
croakies is back in a dragon development
i know chris is the newer player but her
position is better at this point
danny on move four the players were
still following the game uh martinez
alcantara versus pragnanda all right i
will have you know they are prepared
all right
that's what she was saying too
yes obviously this is how prague played
it
a
to learn to speak spanish just from
watching her stream and talk about chess
because it's actually a fair
battleground where i understand enough
about chess that i start i'm already
starting to pick up common words i mean
i know most of the things i say are
complete bs on these shows i do have a
phd in bs um but i was serious about
that like that would be an interesting
human experiment how long will it take
for danny to learn spanish
yeah i i understood uh like 90 it's just
hard to translate live because it that
the audio when you're on zoom cuts in
and out so i don't know if i start
talking and then she keeps she was just
trying to figure out whether she was
gonna take the knight she didn't wanna
she doesn't like to lose bishops so she
doesn't like bishop takes knight which
is actually very good for a beginner
because a lot of beginners are like ha
ha bishop can take horse bishop must
take horse and then
that's like the end of the thought
process right um but she's looking to
create an attack it's just hard to do
but if she okay knight d5 is obviously
like
you know it's it's the computer hates it
because i think knight d4 is a force
yeah i think i think that's got to be
the move that wins a piece actually but
okay croakies
may not see that um
a lot of the analysis like for a lot of
the beginners watching besides the memes
on not understanding what she's saying
or calling uh croaky irish this seems to
be like 90 of the chat at the moment um
it's very important to like
look what your opponent wants to because
they're
she never really did that and you want
moves not to surprise you so move like
knight d4 knight e5 you realize they
attack your queen so you need to
consider both those moves he might see
it because now his knight's going to be
hanging yeah so yeah
it's going to be one of those
unfortunate circumstances for grissom
that she she kind of forces him to come
up with the move and not taking any
credit away from croakies but yeah right
on cue he sees it
and
it's funny but levi said is really true
though even though in this position the
best thing for her to do probably was
just to eliminate that knight
and avoid all these tactics she didn't
want to do it for good reason because
normally giving up a bishop for a night
is is a wasted trade but um
she's gonna have a lot of positive
things to build on this and we know that
she'll be working with anna for the next
couple weeks and anna rudolph is pretty
much coaching half the pogchamps field
because she's a beast um that's what she
does
um
like you said she's giving like private
master class recorded video lessons for
the pogchamps participants
yep yep and uh anna's a gangster um we
spoke about it she's like the she's
gonna become the national trainer of all
creators of spain which the
spanish-speaking audience on twitch is
pretty big and she seriously realized in
coaching rubius like that it's it's
pretty big it's not like
you know you still gotta master the
youtube algorithm and everything but she
makes a lot of content now in uh
in spanish
yep
yeah the uh
the there are other coaches too quick
shout out to all of them everyone who's
working hard with the streamers it's a
lot of fun because some of those lessons
don't happen on stream right it's a lot
of fun to do collabs and you know people
kind of get to know each other but a lot
of the coaching for pogchamps
participants is not necessarily streamed
like my secret session with jimmy
yesterday ludwig got away with one i
wanted beast to beat ludwig so bad i
hope he's watching he did man he did
actually i love him
but yeah
no ludwig ludwig's awesome um but
i think jimmy took about six months off
his life in that match so
it was a good thing or a bad thing but
uh yeah
man there's a lot of analysis on the
screen of croakies we should pop in
he's really scared of bishop takes pawn
take
[Music]
higher
then i think um my knight is here i can
take this pawn with the bishop
[Music]
that i might be able to throw the game
but i'm taking this bishop
[Music]
why why are you playing chess if you're
not doing this
you've got to take this piece
i like that attitude
yeah
[__] me man
this is um funny because it it really is
just a free bishop but he is very scared
of the fork
because my bishop and my queen are
looking in right there's no there's no
upon move i don't think
he's taking his time though i like that
too
yeah the hardest part
the hardest part about calculation is
you don't know if you're you don't know
the final step which is evaluate so
he's very uncertain but the final step
is am i better at my worst and then i
make the most okay so
is there is there a video anywhere where
people can learn how to calculate
uh
it's actually funny i understand that
that was like a volleyball setup and i'm
supposed to be like my videos but uh i
yeah i think so i have a i think i have
a video but it it's
it's it's something you can watch in a
video and convince yourself you can do
in the first game you play after
watching the video you still have your
queen it's so funny
i totally agree with that and as someone
who's transitioned fully to obviously
you know running a chess company but you
know occasionally i get to be a chess
teacher like for pog champs
and a lot of things i say it sometimes
in those lessons let me i'm like yeah
that was a really good piece of advice
even even from me that was a good piece
of advice and then i remember oh but
when i play it's really hard to follow
that it's really hard to do
even though i know it's the right
principles of how to calculate how to
you know how to discern between the good
and bad moves and how to eliminate
things and like you said evaluate at the
end of a line but it's easier said than
done so
yeah and sometimes you legitimately
don't know uh you like
no human can tell if a position is point
five or point two right it's just
and the grand masters do it much more
consistently and much uh much more
accurately and that's that's what makes
the levels in chess and computers
beyond that are just so good at playing
moves that look like they do nothing and
yet just control the board for five to
ten moves so
um
chris is drawing an arrow from every
pawn i'm mildly concerned
what's crazy is it's likely not gonna be
seen
there's some crazy attacking ideas right
now against the white king but um
i mean forget about the fact that black
has a mating net that's a very good move
and croakies
likely likely is not going to see the
most forcing continuation here
no but luckily for him even queen a2 is
probably just very good but the game
could get very interesting if her king
starts running
to d2e2f1 you know um
her attack looks good but the rook on a
will cover anything on the back rank
unfortunately but maybe she gets to b7 i
don't know
for those who keep looking at the eval
bar the evil email bar saying a forced
mate i'll just show you of course it was
this bishop takes b2 and after king
takes you can play queen a3 check and
then when the king goes you actually
flip over
this way so kind of a fun little mating
net that was a little bit unnecessary
and as levy said just taking the apon is
pretty good
yeah bishop b2 is like
i don't know two percent chance of
happening uh in in games
even
like i think your minimum elo should be
fifteen sixteen hundred to see this one
this is bad for us
yeah um
unless uh seriously
about this game i think there's no like
libby says give this check and she might
but
as long as she gets the king out
this game is not over yet because she's
created a really good possibility with
this battery between your brother
already attacking um
hold on danny we're vaping we're vaping
that's a big pull what is he
see
is he still pulling or is he just
holding it there oh my god
that was like a 30-second inhale
oh my gosh
the comment the commentary on i mean
that's a whole nother video series
coming out
i don't even know if this pen is good
man
look at that you want to do that i don't
know if it gives up check me but
whatever
does he realize the bishop oh my god
he's going to
that bishop is not protected there
uh
he played
he played oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god
this is
she could just take it
he he just forced her
to see maybe a winning move let's get
the double look
and she sees that she's trying to get i
did not want to play
oh my god
what am i talking what am i doing
[Music]
brutal and you know what's crazy what
did i just do
now everything changes so now
now the emotions that are going through
he's like oh my god i choked this game
is over this game's over i'm dead lost
now she might be panicking she's like
wait i might be winning like what i
might win this i might win this game oh
she is you can see her she's like she's
freaking out so freaking out and she
still she still can lose like if she
plays rook d2 to try to double rooks and
mate on the eight she gets mated on a1 i
mean it's
oh this is nuts what a crazy game the
machine is just saying it's equal
don't call for you know what happens in
pog champs every time we we suggest
ideas like that it's like it's like it's
spoken into existence um
no you're right despite that blunder
sh she's still i mean one wrong move
away from just getting mated herself
still so this is this is wild
files
gray
[Music]
wow
i'll win the stupid goddamn game
yeah croakies has been a lot more
talkative since he blundered i think
he's a little frustrated himself
danny you lied
what'd i say
[Music]
oh about him being talkative he was yeah
i could see it dude
chris is playing like a boss rookie one
if you listen very closely chat you can
hear the excited squeals of anna rudolph
from across the globe
[Music]
i i'm really confused
why the engine hated queen c3
and what it wanted instead i have like
legitimately no idea it went from equal
to just completely winning for white but
isn't the idea to just run the king
anyway like what what were you supposed
to do i have no idea i agree it looks
yeah i don't know
legitimately clueless i have no idea
what's the difference but he's he's
going to be protecting
it's a good idea maybe he sees that he
can bail out with a draw i mean matt's
strategy right the meta game is all he
needs is a half point uh-oh
and the fact that she went there worries
me she doesn't realize she can move the
king to e2 and get out does she does she
know the repetition rule i don't know
i can't tell if what she just said is
explaining the rule but she'll prob she
needs to run to the king side that's
what she needs to do now
miss click
frisk
moving his queen to a different square
oh man
oh my gosh
listen i don't know much spanish but i
know what gojoles means
dude she's walking her king the wrong
way he's going back to the queen's life
[Music]
i don't know how i get back here man
the room is
[Music]
danny i have a theory i think he's gonna
check her with the knight oh my god
oh my god
[Music]
dude if she goes to the right square
she's going to be winning but
this is so scary
because when you coordinate your queen
at night incorrectly you could just lose
your knight yep and now
i think c4 check is winning for black
must be
but does he see that
d4 check would be huge
because you can't check with the queen
anymore that's the problem
does he realize
i don't think so somebody yelled croaky
oh he moved
but he didn't give a check
oh my god she has mate on he ate oh she
thinks she's in check she thinks she's
in check oh my gosh
she think that she all knows oh no
he gets the rook
he's gonna win now
and he suddenly woke up to his clock
look at him almost
pre-moving oh my god she she had mate on
the board
puts her king on the wrong square oh my
god what's going on here
it's me oh it's mate
he august queens you can take it she
doesn't
oh my god he found a way to win the rook
he found a way to win the rook
this is so crazy
[Music]
now i want to cry
oh man
i mean she's saying she wants to die oh
my god it was a slight upgrade from last
time
oh my god that was
i don't know how we how we choose the
play of the game there
but
so many moments
we were watching them the eval bar is
going crazy both sides
danny king g5 king f6 queen g7 mate dude
if she walks the king up and danny if
danny if that happens 100 gifted subs to
chess.com i will do it 100 gifted subs
if f6 queen g7 or king of six queen
seven hundred gifted subs call your
friends oh my god it's so close
it's a safe bet for you there's no way
he doesn't give one more check and it's
over aye
no
ah
damn
i'm so sad danny i'm sad that was wild
i think i think the craziest moment was
when she borderline pre-moved her king
because she thought she was in check or
she thought she was gonna flag him one
or the other she she was aware of the
clock and that's where it slipped away
[Music]
yay
[Applause]
[Music]
made in two
one
oh my god
that's how we feel too
yeah that's how we feel too
that was a a 2-0 score in the end for
croakies the person who we knew was the
heavy favorite
but that did not go down the way we
thought it would and on that note let's
jump right back to the eternal play of
the game because
man oh man
was it interesting
levy i'm going to let you take us
through it because i think you
recognized what was going on in this
position
right c4 that could have been boom goes
the dynamite
right yeah yeah i i knew i knew when uh
the king moved to d1 that i had a bad
feeling he was going to play knight c3
check because it's just your human
instinct but yeah queen and knights
don't coordinate that well when it's so
close range yeah and he had to go c4 and
c4 leads the white king out either into
the center or to take the pawn and open
up black stroke which is just not
something you're thinking about
and he didn't and she just
thought that she was getting checked and
rookie ate his mate ricky's mate he took
the pawn and this was our play of the
game right here you see the evil eval
bar doing what it does popping up the
board
and she i think levy i think it was less
that she thought it was check i think
she saw his clock and just was trying to
like flag him i think she was like oh my
god i'm gonna win on time
and this this was her opportunity for a
checkmate and two and
um unfortunately for
chris she doesn't find it instead she
moves the king and from there on out i
mean honestly we could call a million
others there was a million checkmates
another blunder right here it was wild
oh my god yeah and she saw it she knew
she kept saying after she made the move
that she missed that the queen could
take the queen so she saw it
well i think she was in full blitz mode
because of his time and ultimately
that'll be experience that she gets and
overall
that'll pay off in future in future pog
champs so
well as she gets more experience remind
the fans that was our eternal play of
the game and uh
you need to be you need to be taking
part in in in the experience of signing
up at eternal.gg
if you do so all you have to do is type
eternal in the chat
uh to to nominate a moment so if you
think that moment deserve to be
eternalized typing type eternal in the
chat right now the play of the game that
receives the most votes will be turned
into a digital collectible and dropped
in the collectible pack coming out on
september 12th the one that i just
purchased i'm all over it along with a
lot of other people
and let's also remind everybody that
starting today august 31st you can
pre-order the pogchamps ford pack on
that note just as i did there's already
been uh more than 10k sales it's going
like crazy that was a wild moment sign
up now with your twitch account i
literally went to eternal.gg i i i know
this is crazy levy i'm telling you it's
so easy everybody should do it all you
do is go to eternal jaw gg and then you
can connect your twitch account with one
click
uh and uh so the fact that it's that
easy
is why is why they're winning it's easy
yeah this website is sick yeah i'm like
wow
it's funny cards cards made such a
nostalgic uh return you know because i
remember back in the day getting my get
my yu-gi-oh box and then trying to draw
until i got rainbow dragon and crying
because i didn't even get any like were
you were you
i played pokemon video games but i
collected yu-gi-oh cards
oh okay so you were one of the weird
ones yeah
well that was i mean we didn't even need
the intro to that i mean we already knew
that but all right uh
yes
don't go anywhere everyone more more
ahead we're gonna have interviews with
the players we got another match coming
up wild stuff all right pogchamps 4
presented by coinbase continues after
this short break
not like a really good move
there's so much free [__] i can get this
too for free
like realistically i want to get this up
f6 yeah i can't but then the pawn just
takes
that's the right move though
i guess that's whatever
i feel like both moves were fine i guess
that's just a quicker checkmate
they both put on the same thing no like
it would have done the same exact thing
i guess that's because i'm putting him
in check that's the only reason why it's
better
like realistically i take this with this
right
okay what's the king can't take that i
guess the queen could oh wait the king
could move here
i guess that's how it makes sense the
king can move here and escape
the rook is hanging what is what does a
hanging rook mean what does that mean
[Music]
it's unprotected
oh i'm seeing it i didn't even see
that so i have to get him in check so
the queen can't move that makes sense
see that's why i'm bad at chess i didn't
even i didn't even see that the queen
was gonna take that that's insane i'm
gonna lose
gg
i can't do any more of these puzzles
either
oh
[Music]
okay just wait
i said we're gonna start 15 minutes ago
i've already drank all my tea
[Music]
yeah i'm playing against rubius
i could make more tea tea is good
i think i'll just wait though
i don't want to miss it
you shall wait
we're back with it's going to be a
special interview here we've got
everybody on the call including pablo la
fuente from chess.com pablo you're a
grand master so you're uniquely
qualified to translate some chess here
on pogchamps
let's see
let's see um yeah i've been following
the the games from yeah well i i'm going
to start with a question for for uh for
chris then going through you pablo
did did you realize that you were that
you were this close to winning in that
last game you actually had checkmate on
the board there okay so you're nodding
you already understood the question it's
okay
i'm not saying that to feel bad i'm
saying that to feel encouraged you
played you played fantastic yesterday
thank you i will answer in spanish but i
understand everything so it's okay you
pablo
um
i wanna cry right now
yeah she says that um as soon as she
moved actually the wrong piece she
realized that we can all sit on on her
stream
and that from that point onwards like
mentally she went downhill and she
couldn't really she couldn't really
recover
yeah i was going to ask you
croaky i i was um
when you made the blunder on age six
what was the mindset was the mindset oh
my god i gotta not lose because it
seemed like you were still playing for
like a win you kept attacking the king
um and at what point did you realize
that you had blundered because was it
the time
when when when did it happen for you
i i didn't realize until she took the
queen i don't know why i i thought i was
setting up a pen i just like completely
forgot the rules of chess in the middle
of the game and i was just like
i for some reason i thought the queen
could not take my bishop i thought i was
setting up a pen and then i couldn't
believe it when when the queen took my
bishop and i was just panic mod so i had
a couple of like moves previously i'd
like tried to prepare for an attack on
on her king
and i just thought okay well i'll just
have to continue with that now and then
it was just it was horrific worst game
of chess i've ever played and i'm
i was completely panicked just trying to
find i don't know what i don't know what
i did in the last like 30 moves i'm just
moving my queen around trying to find
checks trying to find the queen back
trying to be able to bring the queen
back to defend because like i saw that
the rooks were coming in the queen was
coming in and i was
i i couldn't i couldn't focus i was just
making checks trying to maneuver my
queen a wee bit and
yeah it was it was
rough but
chris back to you we know this is your
your podcamp's debut right were you were
you nervous for your first match here
barry
muyama
yeah she says that just five minutes
before the game started she was
extremely nervous but as soon as the
game actually started she she relaxed
and she actually uh got into it and
enjoyed it
so it was a yeah it was a very good
experience well i'll give i'll give one
more to chris and then throw it to levy
to close us out but chris you we know
you've been working hard with anna and
she's amazing can you tell us a little
bit of of your plans for the next couple
weeks lots of chess with coach rudolph
and how has it been to work with the one
and only anna chess here to get ready
for pogchamps
[Music]
[Laughter]
so first of all she says that ana is
incredibly um it's uh
it's just gifted as a teacher the way
she explains things and how she make it
very deducted and
so she's very happy about that
and also she says that anna have been
actually prepared uh for this particular
match so actually anna prepared against
her opponent for today
so it was uh it was very professionally
done
so yeah and i think that's it i don't
remember if you said anything
[Music]
yeah and i also told her that i mean not
to have
very high expectations for this match
certainly
she will she will
get her chances at the at the next uh
the losers like the consolation uh
bracket
so yeah just to go relax and enjoy the
the the opportunity but not to put so
much pressure on on her
makes sense i danny i don't know if we
have time for one more question um but i
was going to ask both
of the players we can start with uh
croakies and then we can we can ask
chris also i'm just curious what
what is chess like uh in in in both of
your
both of your countries like for even
from an early age were you playing chess
or is it something that you got into uh
as adults and then your resources we
know for chris it's anna but i'm curious
to hear uh from both so we can start
with cookies
i played like a little bit when i was a
lot younger just with like brothers and
and family and
played a little bit of chess then but i
hadn't really played until
since then until this year it's always
been something i wanted to to learn but
and i knew it's like a huge time sink
isn't it so to kind of get get across
the first hurdle has always been a
struggle but
now that i've started learning is i mean
i'll definitely be continuing to play
after
nice and just uh just one thing uh levy
and danny if i can if i can add that i
remember now that i forgot to say that
um
mentioned it she only started playing a
month ago
which is absolutely incredible what
she's been doing now so yeah
just
she says that
her father taught her how to play but it
wasn't until queen's gambit came around
that that
that was what actually triggered
her interest and
she's actually very happy not only with
the game itself but also with the
community so she's very eager to to
continue playing
well this has been great thank you so
much to to both both of you uh croakies
obviously congratulations and uh and and
and chris as well a great match and
can't wait to see where this event goes
uh and pablo
you're a pretty good translator you
should consider doing it for a living
maybe for a chess company
um so anyway thank you all and uh
have a good rest of your day
we'll we'll let you get to it
all right thanks guys see you guys
but as they sign out
we sign on to reminding the community
we're raising money for rise above the
disorder remember this is an amazing
cause
so many people struggle with mental
health issues and usually what deters
them from from getting the help they
need is access and affordability and so
they provide the support for people to
get
get they get the help they need for free
it's a super amazing cause you can use
the command rad use the command donate
click the button no excuses no matter
where you are chess tv if you're
watching there there's a button below
the player twitch youtube everywhere we
really appreciate your support still
still hopeful that we might get to 2000
on the day i'm i'm calling it out there
we might might have a great run here in
this last round i hope you guys
guys and gals can all jump in
uh levy we need to jump really quick i
think to our to a break and when we come
back we will have
the second match of the day with puns
versus rubius
don't go anywhere all you poggers out
there we'll be right back with pogchamps
ford presented by coinbase
he gave me a link hold on
i will click link
okay
oh this tea is way too hot to drink
right now
nope
not don't want to burn my tongue no
thanks
i'm waiting
and you didn't have to do anything okay
[Music]
i don't know if i think i'm in the right
spot i clicked the link they gave me
and i made
tea back in two than game time alright
sounds good
do you guys see the mcc
uh twitter
they announced next mcc on the 18th
no we're losing today probably
damn there's been almost 10 million
games played there's 200 000 people
playing right now on this website that's
insane
i don't know why my name has a canadian
flag
that's a great question
i'm not canadian but
maybe like when i first
made my account like i had a vpn on and
i was like in canada like ip or
something i don't know but i'm
definitely not in canada
you can change it uh it's kind of funny
though
what's up sneak
i do say some words with a canadian
accent though like
when i say like sometimes when i say
house
about
and
room
like they kind of like sound a little
bit canadian
canadian-esque
[Music]
yo thanks for the raid anna pog
thank you guys
welcome welcome welcome welcome
i'm ready to lose this chess match
i have my tea ready it's hot right now i
can't sip on it yet i don't want to burn
my tongue
but we wait
welcome raiders
terrible
hey my name is darshan and today i
wanted to talk to you guys a little bit
about mental health
taking care of my own mental health has
probably been the biggest improvement to
my quality of life so
today i wanted to highlight an
organization named rad who has been
doing a great job of helping people with
their mental health
with just 30 dollars you could save
someone one week of their fee
and so
any amount that you could donate would
be a great help to rat and i think that
they're doing a wonderful thing
[Music]
and we're back here
reminding everyone
more amazing reasons to donate to our
charity also more amazing reasons for
our players to play there's a lot of
cash on the line that's i mean
pretty pretty decent uh decent payday
for for playing a an event for a few
hours total
chess
and uh each group for some of them okay
sorry what
yeah i said for some of them i mean some
of them will only play a few hours but
some might
go all the way they'll
you know 20 grand for about 10 hours of
chess yeah
it's not so much too bad
plus the content the content is fun we
see rubius just went live
he's usually rocking somewhere between
30 and 50k viewers over there a lot of
people tuning in to see the number one
uh streamer in spain uh number three
most followed channel on twitch overall
if you didn't know that about rubios and
you got puns i think he's a minecrafter
variety streamer um
and um
he's ready to play too he's been alive
for a little bit doing some training
doing some puzzles so this will be fun
to get the two of them going it looks
like the game has begun
and i will uh bring it up right here
yeah so what is
the rubious opening repertoire uh it
looks is it it's a scandy
looking like
yeah like a scandinavian
hmm
over the last few months i can tell you
man even though he lost that first match
on day 102 he played amazing that the
first game he had against against
croakies he was he was winning and then
a single blunder lost it but he he
played
really well against croakies
and he looks like he's doing good here
it's fascinating how
players who come back to chess at
different times of their life
end up sticking to the game because
ultimately that's like one factor that
is different for everyone you can we can
all put in six hours but my six hours
will be different than your six hours so
um
yeah i mean croakies is clearly
something is sticking very very well
like a sponge um
it was one of the reasons like michelle
recently celebrated hitting a thousand
and i said
i saw some people being like why are we
celebrating this and i mean a lot of
people go through the exact same thing i
mean some people can get to a thousand
in a month of playing and some people it
takes them a long time and i mean as
long as you're a positive person in the
community and
spreading trust to many people we gotta
we gotta support you too i don't know if
we have eyes on
puns but
i think i think we do
oh there we go doesn't seem too
talkative right now but what wasn't it
[Music]
you're the best i want to be on one of
your videos that's sorry that came out
oh he's gonna get a free pawn here i
don't like that
dude i think that was part of the song
no i just vaguely heard noises because i
i can't fully hear you like because
we're on the stream
so i heard the beats and i just heard
you talking in the background and then i
was like wait he's rapping i don't know
i want to trade another horse i could i
could theoretically move here and then
take a bishop
but i don't feel like i think that's
just a bad idea
oh my gosh the zoom was crazy
zuma's crazy
anyways i'm down to get that out of the
way i'll trade upon
yeah girl let me show you something
i wanna do some chess move music
like marvin gaye
what would that sound like
[Music]
by the way this chest is fantastic right
now damn it i don't like that
i want to move my thing here
move his thing there
sometimes it's good to move your thing
there and sometimes you you don't that's
just inappropriate so in this case
uh
completely appropriate and uh yeah danny
as you said the eval bar is
vibing like this is a pog champs record
borderline equality after 12 moves i
mean i'm i'm loving it yeah
yep
is he ever referenced in any form of pop
culture ever
he might be yeah he might be i i don't
know who's canceled and not so you have
to be very careful i should be careful
right because if i talk about someone
who's been canceled then then i get
canceled isn't that how it works it's
like it's like a it's like contagious
it's like a virus you're you're kind of
uncancelable because i've already said
so much dumb ass stuff
yeah
in a way yeah well i don't know i you
but
no you're you're just you're you're
danny you know what i mean like
that's my brand is being awkward and
like can he get away with saying that
like
i i had someone on staff tell me there's
probably only a couple things you could
ever talk about that would get you
canceled so just don't talk about those
things i said okay
yeah like if you ever tell the people
that on poisson is not forced
actually anarchy chess uh went through
it some time ago somebody posted that on
poisson is not a forced move and they
got absolutely brigaded it was it was
crazy like a bunch of people who buy
into this meme just straight up attack
like this poor teenager who was just
like
got his dms flooded and was super sad
like when memes go too far man 2021
gotta be careful yeah
okay but seriously the eval bar has been
sitting super close to equal these guys
are playing good moves i mean everyone's
developed
um
if if puns kind of recognizes he needs
to complete the king's side development
and get this guy out of the center then
he's really in good shape
[Music]
this is awesome this game is great
why don't we throw a little something on
the line to try to reach 2000 by the day
how about if we reach 2000 levy you and
i will freestyle rap together harry max
style
uh how about if we reach 2000 you
freestyle but i'll drop the beat for you
okay even better even better
um yeah i gotta write my reps i'm not
you know i'm not uh could we could we
pull it harry max now could we like have
a have a scene that pulls up chat and
i'll highlight words as we go
let's do it
let's do it if we reach 2000 i'm gonna
freestyle rap harry max style pulling
words from the chat in real time
so get us to 2000 today
and that's your treat yeah
don't say i don't you
they don't feed you baby birds mama's
here we've got some got some good good
chests going on too so you know maybe
some single person come in and drop like
600 bucks right now just to make sure it
happens
all right
what rook b1 now
yep how sharp is well puns wants to take
but
wait so danny in in in chess.com play
you guys can also force games you can
like start the games yeah you can do all
the things you can do in live now
besides
one particular thing the um the you know
like the analysis board that we used to
use for like the live events
that's not in play which is partly why
we built it but pretty much everything
else is there um
interface is a little different but yeah
you should at some point you should give
it a try when you have a little extra
time to set up your stream with some
different captures and stuff
yeah i like this this is a high-level
chess game from
this is
this is um rubius is focused by the way
look at him
he's got that mustache where you can't
tell if it's purposeful or not
is he is he going for that look or
should he have shaved like what's going
on with his facial hair right i was
going to ask that the difference between
rubius now and rubios of old is that
ruby is now is like couple hundred
points higher and has the and is rocking
the stash
don't hang your queen rubius
don't take on d3
yes don't do it
i think he sees it he's now
oh he's slide
so he's playing
meanwhile i'm i am absolutely fascinated
by the production going on behind the
scenes here i'm not even staring at the
chessboard if only chat could see how
much cards are putting on the show
yeah y'all just click the button and
spend like three hours memeing with us
this is some hard work i'm watching it
go down i am fascinated how many there
we go there we go
the the lights right behind the scenes
um yeah
so
i just want y'all to
uh we got we got some grand masters in
the live chat of the game shout out to
chess weebs providing some
in-game typed commentary i like that
you know danny i was on the chess.com
forums today
and um i was looking up different queen
sacrifices that computers have played
and i saw the most recent forum was
someone asking if if i'm strong or not
as a player and there was a title player
in there who was like is he strong as a
player as strong as i was 30 years ago
and as a creator he's absolute garbage
which is why people like him and i was
like
man we need more grand masters like
chess weeps my man is just hanging out
in the in the game chat providing the
the written comments for folks
he's not knocking anybody yeah you know
it's like
so shout out to chess weeps shout out to
you chad guys
if you can't listen with audio you got
to go to the game chat and chess weebs
will provide you the written analysis of
the game so that's
got mad love for a man dennis and he
said ruby is better here for sure he's
right and rubius takes the pawn on d3
dude the guy
is balling and he played he played super
well like i said against croakies and
only lost because of a
a a bit of a time scramble blunder um
and so
yeah he's improved a lot
puns is in a little bit of trouble here
yep
now rubius is you could say rubius is
playing better than some gm's himself
well queen d6 knight d3 very logical
good move there
he takes b7 this is a high level game
right now you got the dynamic of the
knight imbalance versus the bishops i
mean this is
we could we could make a video on this
if only we knew a really popular chess
youtuber who makes videos
man only a new one of those i could call
a god mature danny you have a youtube
channel
you have a youtube channel
oh man
okay
um
wait you do want youtube channel what
what
i see you do have a youtube channel
though right yeah you know but like most
things i do they're subpar and worse
than the rest of the options so why go
to mine when they go to yours
um yeah except for chess websites we we
are the only chess website on the
internet so
that one we've got on lock um
that's true by the way queen b1 is
genius can i just like can i just give
props where it's due like what
this is crazy brook attacks the knight i
love it
is playing good chess here
yeah if black plays knight c5 i'll be
super impressed i think rook takes rook
is gonna be played it's just too obvious
because you're like oh my god my knight
is hanging and
just don't go queen a6 i can see why uh
black like getting a little distracted
being like queen a6 defends my knight
and also attacks the rook but nope
oh
94.
it seems like a great idea because you
attacked the bishop you win another pawn
but if puns sees that he can trade first
and then take the knight it actually
solves all the problems it wins a piece
and defends the bishop let's see what
he's thinking about
he can also take both knights
checkmate here soon actually i don't
know
a lot of feedback here from one check
with
yeah i'll do this move
too defensive just to protect this i'll
take another trade do it keep doing it
[__] it you keep trading i don't care
i'm playing so defensive because i can't
i don't i'm not i'm on the defense right
here like i can't like make an offensive
move because he keeps attacking [__]
he is attacking believe
i just want to take this pawn that's all
i want that's my next move if i can do
it
he could have just done it
he could have done it
but i could have done at that move
couldn't i wait what did he do again
you went here i could have taken it that
turn couldn't have or am i just getting
my own head now no because he's
attacking this now but i would have
moved it and attacked it i'm so dumb
whatever
that's what my mom used to say
that's a bad move
and then at one point she was like
actually you're just young like that's
just yeah
you see up you're still learning 25
years later
oh he's a fork now i'll take a trade
nothing like giving back handed
compliments accidentally
creating commentary right when i want to
say something i'm scared to interject
the thought process
[Music]
oh and now he stops
exactly
oh look at that subbie mode like a
kitten coming out of a box
adorable af
a minute and a half on him this is fine
queen f7 is coming
oh
see upon sees it his brook and queen are
trying to get one
okay he's literally like it's even
except he has three pawns above me
it's not even and he had what do i have
i have a rook a bishop
and he has a rook
and a knight
we both have queens
i'm not sure which is i mean there are
even points like oh knight and a bishop
are both worth three
but i'm not sure which one is actually
more useful
i'll take this pawn next turn depending
on what they do
we're two minutes ahead we're two
minutes ahead he's taking a while
amazing
we disney keep playing fast make him
fall under the pressure
good idea i mean honestly he's
playing the practical meta game put him
on under under time pressure and now
rubius is under three minutes
honestly i can put him in check here
because then if he takes i'll just no i
don't want to risk that drink to queen
trade actually
that i could
that'll do with chess brawls who just
raided us 700 viewers thanks guys
also shout out to chris earlier
or something what does he do so if you
joined us and this is a free pawn that's
all i know
thanks for coming and he also gets a
free pawn hopefully you also speak
english
[Music]
i need to attack i need to attack this
knight
and then it's in a bad position for me i
don't like the night being there so
let's attack it let's get the [__] out
get the [__] out of my property
get off my lawn kids
chess commentary should be like that
yeah i can get well
sitting here for me to take as well
and i can also attack this rook if i
just move my queen here
attack the rook
okay
oh
okay if you go there to the queen
sheboygan wisconsin don't do it okay
carla don't okay
are we both just gambling
here
we're both his gambit oh my god i'm such
an idiot okay that hurts play time play
time i just gave him a free win but it's
okay we can still
we could still win this
oh that was bad okay play time went off
time i blundered my queen it's okay
dude it's fine
i didn't do that that wasn't me you're
looking at the wrong stream
okay i have a feeling that puns is going
to be great content for the rest of this
blockchain it's the first time i've
actually heard him and that was
as he got more comfortable despite the
botes gambit
right there on c6 we got a drop in
alexander beautes emote
despite the botest game but he's got a
good attitude he's going to try to flag
rubius i love it
that's gonna definitely be difficult
rubius
has a pretty simple game plan here don't
get checkmated and push pawns
yeah he's gonna play e3
e2
e1
so
yeah it's
gonna be rough for a first game yeah
rubius
super solid
he's playing very well
e3
yeah he is he's playing super well and
he only really had one mistake in that
game when he took that opponent e4 with
the knight um
also another student of anna rudolph is
rubios like you said the entire
the entire country of spain entire
spanish-speaking streaming audience at
some point we'll be taking lessons from
you know
yeah i don't think he's in spain i think
he's in andorra right yeah sorry he's in
there
but
uh close close by i think how many miles
you know um
geography
is a thing yeah
got two rules on my shows no math and no
geography
googling where boom
[Music]
he has a few mates
he sees it
let's check it out
let's [__] go
whoa
it was epic
you know i remember the days i
celebrated victories like that
haven't won a game since
i was going to say i i was like you know
uh
you know i always felt like
over-the-board chess should be like that
at some point you went to vegas recently
we should all go to a tournament and
just sell it and just like just bring it
bring the celebration that's the post
game energy we need
get out to rubius for the dub
yeah because when you win games in
classical especially against a strong
player you leave and you have the silent
beaming moment and you walk into the
elevator like i'm so good at chest but i
would love to just you know like my
opponent resigns and i'm like
and then they're like
what you know td is like
right you know and then you got like the
[__] people in america i don't know
what that sounds worse i don't know i
shouldn't have said that
yeah but you know what
well i can't do it in my next tournament
because it's a small venue but next time
i play like a giant tournament i'm gonna
yell td we'll shush me and all just well
he's like trying to fight the tv did you
actually see fedo
at the feeding world cup
i i i very rarely have never seen that
he gave he gave us like a fist pump when
his when that was actually a pretty cool
moment um so like i don't i don't care
about stuff like i see that and i'm like
oh that's funny but i i know people were
mad about it like for sure because it's
very much
like you don't do that stuff at that
like you've never seen that before for a
reason nobody does that right so i could
you know people were like very
unprofessional and i was like you know
why do people care so much about
everything just show what happens on
shows when i do together we just start
talking like i feel like we can you and
i could just talk or not talk for hours
and that's our relationship
and and did you hear that fide is uh
considering revoking his privilege to
play tournaments for six months for that
fist pump are you serious
no no i'm not
my god levy
you shut your mouth when you're talking
to me everyone don't go anywhere we'll
be right back
i blended the queen
what a what a dumb move i should have um
what was the move i should have gone
here
i mean i could have went is it my turn
right now yeah okay it's my turn
i could have just come on here right
this is a free move
or what
you would have taken let's say i go like
that
the queen will take this
no it's not even i'm still in a wacky
position position here
i don't know
my opening was [__]
i had no
what [__] me is when he went like this
at the very start let me go back
him moving this
i do i didn't know what to do
i don't know how to come back after that
that i was not ready for that
[Music]
and it caused me to like
like five of my opening moves where me
just moving my goddamn horse and i ended
up losing it anyways
and i have nothing developed i have
three pawns out and he has two pawns and
two real pieces
and after that it's just like my i have
nowhere to move i'm i'm
confined
like look it up look how [__] i can't
move this i can't move this
i can't i can barely move this
like it's bad
meanwhile he can like move all his
pieces freely
oh this end game i think it's just i
just will lose this i had so much more
time than he did if i didn't blunder my
queen i think i just win
just off time
well
next game should be starting soon
i came in just expecting to lose anyways
so i don't care
if i lose
[Music]
how many are stacked up
uh
[Music]
oh i thrown it okay
oh i have to go back oh crap i have to
make a new tab for that
let's do this
we're back with game two between puns
and rubios coming right up with me the
one and only levy rosman if you're just
tuning in to day three of pogchamps four
where have you been if you happen to be
finding us from somewhere random on the
world wide web and you're lost call for
help use your phone if you have one find
somebody close to you or hit the follow
button and then you'll get alerts every
time the chess channel goes live um
levy
when do i get to start dressing like i'm
about to do a chess youtube video or i'm
going to be in a good fellas movie like
walking out of a casino with ray liotta
right next to me i.e levee rosman's
outfit
i see i see yeah so this shirt uh has a
legendary comment associated with it
uh it's not super family friendly but
i'm going to say it anyway because when
is pogchamps family friendly someone
once said about the shirt that i look
like i'm about to bump a line of coke
and go fight a bunch fight a bunch of
asian dudes that's um that's what
someone said about the shirt in a very
famous youtube comment one of the rare
positive pinned comments on the gotham
chess youtube channel
i really like this shirt so first of all
it's from a brand called all saints okay
uh and um
it's uh it's just pretty and it's soft
and uh and i and you know that's those
are two positive adjectives for many
many things and i i like the shirt but
danny you listen we were talking about
this on the break you you could rock any
t-shirt and that's my goal that's why i
actually started going to the gym
because i wanted to look like you yeah
and
i forget you know
um so
lovie it's so funny we just totally
improv i just impromptu had to tease you
about the shirt and you you uh responded
with the most legendary youtube comment
ever that's hilarious but that was my
thought i'm looking at you i'm like is
he is he about to walk out of a casino
right like or is
all right i
i can't tell you how much the last
nearly two years with this whole
pandemic thing have destroyed my ex the
extroverted part of my personality yeah
and i like being indoors so much but man
i cannot wait to travel somewhere it's
just
it's i i really but who knows probably
2022 man
um but yeah by the way this game is
going to explode in the next two movies
so
levy and i will we'll dive into some
chess in a little bit let's see what
ruby is thinking oh he's mad at
xqc just so you know i've talked to him
about it rubius loves being told that he
is
i like the music
between rubios and croakies our next
event vapes
d5 is such a good move seriously
puns
the structure oh my goodness now develop
that bishop to g4
wow
played c6
d5 all right i wouldn't have oh there
yeah yeah
d5 is good c6 is a little bit
questionable but uh here okay
yeah
yeah this is this is very nice for black
but
people don't really play well with that
with no space so he might be tempted to
play like knight uh pawn to f6 for
example and weak in this position but
not he just fires off bishop c5
by the way levi's highlight of d5 is
really key everyone because for someone
of this level it's so common what
happens your piece gets taken and you
just take back you just fire back taking
the pawn and not only is d5 way better
than that but taking actually loses
immediately to this amazing tactic
bishop takes f7 deflecting the king to
win the queen so
levi's this is really a very strong move
from puns again not only not doing the
normal beginner thing to do which is
just take back but finding the really
strong response d5 to keep it closed so
good stuff from puns right now
yeah and he might have stumbled on it by
accident because maybe he saw his queen
could get taken if he trades so he was
like don't don't want to lose my queen
uh i'm very curious to see how strong
rubius has gotten how will he develop an
attack because all his pieces are facing
the king's side now and
to be honest the attack is very close to
just winning okay please rookie one but
i'm i'm wondering
how he'll break through or if he'll just
do something totally random
[Music]
man i uh
h6 is good good move
got that puns music
he tends to be
quieter at the start of games and he
gets more talkative as the game tends to
go on that being puns
again i need my pieces out of here like
these two guys here need to go yeah
good job i don't want to move this here
though because it'll be useless
this pawn
is in the way
like the pin
in to win with the bishop on g4 and ruby
has attacked the bishop these guys
i'm small in chess in this match
and do i want to go for a trade like
uh-oh he'll have
uh no horses
honestly [__] oh you literally just
said you're live
bishop take horses
yeah and it could get very dangerous now
because the queen can team up with the
light scored bishop so
uh could be a problem
that was a seriously
seriously not ideal trade from puns to
take there
really want to keep that pin here
if rubius finds queen f5
i'm ready to say ruby
one of the winners of his bracket
uh yeah probably i mean it's
right because and yeah he finds it i
mean it's yeah very sharp very good play
but this is not too complex because
black will oh man
i don't think puns sees it oh he doesn't
see it
he doesn't see it
oh no
ruby is seasoned
wait
he's double checking
let's listen into puns the checkmate is
coming
oh we did it
oh man oh well gg
god dammit
[Applause]
foreign
okay
[Laughter]
wow
uh ruby's is the best and uh anna
rudolph should be celebrating i mean he
played
lights out chess i mean the chess.com
computer might
take away points here and there but i
give him a plus both those games so the
gotham uh eval matters more than the cap
score
i i i tend to agree and you know
regardless of the computer's evaluation
of different spots rubius is clearly a
much improved player from pogchamps 3
back in february
and i don't think we have to look too
far for the eternal play of the game
because what we just saw on the board
with the queen
coming up to f5
this is his recognition it's not the
it's not that
as as a player improves levy in their
chess understanding we see it where you
and i have been coaching chess for many
years right it's sometimes not just that
they see the idea but it's how quickly
they see the idea right like he
immediately recognized queen f5 and
queen h7 you know what i'm saying and
and that to me is a sign of how much how
much better he's gotten right here
yeah
uh i think he got his highest rating a
few days ago and
he
well his account is weird because it
says that his highest rating is 1400
because i guess of the way he he started
so he like lost the game and it gets
classified as that but yeah he's he's on
a good streak and
curious to know if he feels like he's
getting better which is also important
yeah well i'm sure he does and i know
he's been doing chess with anna uh for
some time and obviously really since
pogchamps three despite a small break
he's kind of stayed on it and
we see the hard work is is paying off
that was our eternal play the game let's
remind everybody that if you agree that
that moment should be eternalized sign
up right now at eternal dot gg with your
twitch account literally it takes like
three clicks if you're logged into
twitch just open the tab go to
eternal.gg and connect your twitch
account after that and forevermore while
you're watching uh the the pogchamps 4
event all you got to do is type eternal
in the chat every time you see a moment
because maybe you see a moment before we
get to it right all you have to do is
type eternal it'll automatically detect
and connect detect and connect holy god
i am a rapper i was born to rap any
hooters there you go well i mean i'm
going to keep freestyling and spitting
all the chat be fitting but if they get
to 2k i'ma
rhyme all day whoa oh my god i just
blacked out and continued to be awesome
with my rap style harry mack i'm coming
for you let's also remember that all
proceeds uh for the hog champs for
eternal gg packs are going to rad
which is an amazing thing that they
decided to do so uh don't go anywhere
everyone we're going to be right back
with pogchamps 4 presented by coinbase
own streaming history while supporting
your favorite gamers and streamers by
buying their digital collectibles on a
turn
collecting these sometimes hilarious
always epic gaming and irl highlights
directly benefits the creators while
providing you the fans something unique
and special to keep
sign up on eternal.gg build your own
collection and feel the thrill of
ripping digital packs and viewing
amazing moments in the marketplace
[Music]
so
it's interview time for pogchamps 4. we
got to start with you rubius your
future's your future's looking bright is
that why you got the shades on
yes the shades and the moustache it's
it's what gave me the power you know
it's this beautiful mustache i saw the
clip where you
said it you didn't know it was serious
or not but
for this tournament i have it only for
this trust me
okay well don't don't shave don't shave
it i mean obviously you know winning
looks good on you the mustache the
shades look good on you but seriously
man i mean how excited are you to get
get your first match win and and uh what
have you been doing to improve your
chess over the last few months
well uh
it's been uh really cool to finally uh
play better than the last year because i
was a little bit down from yesterday's
match or the
previous match with croakies
because i thought i
i was i did it so well but i failed at
the last moment and that
usually crushes my um i really say my
autoestima pablo self-esteem
yeah auto steve okay yes
yes so
[Music]
um but yeah it was really good matches
with with puns it was
the only thing is uh
i was nervous all the time because i saw
he was playing really good so
i was trying to get to the level i was
with the other match with croakies
i i have a question for you uh yeah
danny and i were super
like complimentary of of both of you you
guys played really really well um i'm
sort of
fascinated puns you you've only played
like 50 rapid games in your life and
that was a very high level match so are
you just naturally
like talented for chess and if you put
in some work uh on the openings and
maybe some like you know dedicated
training or what what's uh is the sky
the limit for you um well i mean i i'm a
gamer at a hard i game all the time and
it's just another game i guess but i've
only played a very few online matches i
played a bunch with my grandpa when i
was younger but nothing like
high competitive like so i don't know i
think if i get work on my openings and
developing pieces i felt like in my
matches with rubius i was like really
clumped together and my pieces were like
just stuck behind my pawns i couldn't
really do much but i think i could be
good at chess but like i don't know if i
want to put the time into it but we'll
see
well what got you back here you said
your grandpa taught you when you're
younger is there was it was are you the
queen's gambit crowd was it pog champs
was what got you into chess here
oh i mean i just saw the opening of like
you guys invited me i was like oh i'm
down to play some chess i was i played
uh in that in that uh speed bullet
tournament the botes bullet one yeah
yeah a while back and i did really bad
in that so i wanted to kind of redeem
myself but that didn't happen here today
maybe in my next match i'll do a better
a bit better but
it was really cool matt
yeah it was fun i had a good time
ruby is there's only officially two
grand masters in andorra so are you
gonna be the third one are you gonna
play on the olympic team what's the plan
yes yes definitely
if i have the help of anna which is the
best teacher in the world of course i
think i can make it all right sounds
good
well
last obviously most important question
rubius what what flavor what flavor
what flavor what
of the vape
oh it's uh it's a custom made it's
called the alien blood and it's like i
mean and stuff yes it's really good
i expected nothing less um
but seriously uh rubius congratulations
man and um obviously it's gonna be an
exciting bracket to see who moves on to
the winner's bracket and the consolation
and puns
yeah well i i agree with with levy right
maybe maybe a couple weeks of focus and
who knows who knows uh where you're
going to be at the end of this thing so
a good good chest today good luck in the
rest of the event
thank you i appreciate it thanks for the
uh
for the interview
um
all right here's our results on the day
as you can see
uh the brackets are starting to take
form levy right we're starting to get
some a clear view on on who maybe who
maybe has the best chance to move on i
think croakies clearly on top of group d
he might win all of his his matches at
this point but rubius right there
um played well today
yeah uh rubius is
his last game i was completely right
well not completely but one point off he
played at 89.1 percent
but i think if you run it on a slightly
different different depth i mean he
might have played 90 percent granted it
was a one mover if uh if puns had played
g6 toward the end we might have had a
longer game but
uh he did what he had to do and
does d flow into c on the bracket like
does d1 play c2 like is that how it
works or
is it a d b c
i have no idea i just i just work here i
have no no
same yeah yeah same here same here i
think a b play i think a and d play in b
and c play but i could be totally wrong
on that and normally i am so i
i um you know they feed me lines i'm
like the ron burgundy yeah yeah by the
way shout out to debbie wrench man who
just donated a hundred dollars to get us
a little bit closer you guys have
t-minus about 10 minutes to get us over
2k if you want me to freestyle rap all
day um although i'm doing it to try to
raise money for a good cause i'm
learning that maybe offering to rap is
deterring people from donating so i
don't know maybe i don't know what i
don't know what the deal is um listen i
think i think a crossfit stream live
from the gym would probably get folks uh
a bit more you're just
truly just offer them you know
dude
it is but you want an inflatable duck in
a in a tub writing subscribers names on
your hands and arms yeah have you
thought about that i'm thinking of a
bikini stream coming up in fact you know
what starting the next pogchamp show
we're going to put some prizes on the
line so we've still got about you know
15 000 total of you across different
platforms i'm going to say this next pog
champs we're going to have a graphic and
maybe we'll have a hot tub stream as a
price because we need to motivate the
crowds to get those donors coming in
because i would love i would i mean
first of all i would love to do a hot
tub stream anyway but maybe we'll think
of some other things let's uh let's
remind everybody the schedule levy
tomorrow is september 1st welcome
september um
and uh we start things off with tech
tone and a guy making his pog champs
debut nick a30 i'm excited for that one
yeah that's an interesting matchup i
know techtone's been on the grind uh and
we have obviously returning from
pogchamps one that's box box
yeah he's been working sapnap has been
farming some block champs tournament uh
and
you know minx's content and harry
mackay's content it's it's like a
beautiful match up there you know it's
chess is gonna be secondary i was just
gonna say
you called it the truth is harry mack is
an absolute beast i mean the rapping
that he did to open up the show i mean
to me made made the whole event i was
like oh my god that was that was
insanely awesome
um and uh minx meek's had a tough go of
it at first but we we hope that she
continues to stick with it and and like
you said it's either way gonna be some
interesting content uh between between
those two and in the match in the middle
of the day
uh speaking of content let's remind
everybody that the eternal play of the
game
what
what happened
levy
yeah
oh
what were you trying to say
i was uh i was just gonna i was gonna
say that harry mack and i
have a thing in common
okay
we have uh
at both at least 80 000 plays on spotify
so i'm just
i'm just saying i there's a little bit
of a lag on zoom you know sometimes i
say something and then you keep talking
i'm like
but you know that's the beauty of
technology no i apologize for that
i i do apologize for that for anyone
watching and tuning in i am i am not
trying to speak over my talented
co-hosts because they're all they're the
reason you're here so i apologize to
levy and i i didn't hear you so i'm glad
my producer told me first of all if
anyone hasn't checked out levy's rap you
should do that um
i've listened to it more times than i'm
comfortable admitting to you on camera
um i have enjoyed your rap um
all right
what i was getting to was the eternal
play of the games every day remember
that you can you can vote in chat all
you gotta do is sign up and lucky
winners are randomly drawn um we uh we
want to remind you that on august 29th
we had uh we had some people taken home
taking home some collectibles via
eternal you see the usernames right
there send me a gift is one that i just
love right there at the top because it
just that just speaks to me send me a
gift um super ginger 2000
uh was um
was a film that simon williams got
accidentally involved in and then and
then had to back out real quick let's
move on to the next slide of usernames
before i say something inappropriate
about that um okay and then we've got uh
on day two uh that was august 30th
yesterday we had some other other lucky
winners taken home
taking home collectible packs brought to
you by eternal we really appreciate it
and remember all the proceeds if you
want to pre-order your pog champs for
collectible packs go towards supporting
uh our our charity that is rise above
the disorder
you know at the end of pogchamps levy we
often wondered we should do something at
the end of pogchamps and and give people
some encouragement to do it sometimes
you watch chess and that makes you want
to play chess sometimes people watch me
play chess and they don't ever want to
be involved again but if you are
interested in looking to throw down go
join the coinbase community cup it
starts at 3 p.m pacific time pretty much
daily
and there are premium membership prizes
so our presenting sponsor is going to
have an event that starts every day when
pogchamps ends you can go join the
coinbase community cup arena win premium
membership prizes and have a blast make
sure you do that um because people you
know they do at the end of a show
they're like well i just got here what
happened uh i missed the show mom i told
you let me come earlier and you didn't
and now i'm just gonna have nothing to
do but now they can go play the coin
base community cup
now is that is is the person yelling at
their mom below the age of 18 or is that
like 13 to 35
what
they're probably a 27 year old man
naked sitting at home on their beanbag
chair like i said eating cheetos um yeah
i'm 25. so i've just missed that uh
target audience
um anyway
what are we doing here again
i don't know i don't know they put the
full cams at the end we're supposed to
say some stuff like to sign off okay uh
thank you yeah what what what do we what
do we do here um you brought me back to
everybody
go ahead
i was gonna say coinbase is awesome uh
eternal on eternal.gg we've already
raised over 16 000
uh one thing i was going to comment on
about uh rad right above the disorder
like i don't know how it is in other
countries but definitely in in in the
u.s like any time my family
had to
uh take me to therapy when i was a wild
teenager or as a family yeah that stuff
is expensive man yeah like we afforded a
few sessions but geez them and lawyers
like several hundreds of dollars an hour
so this is a really good initiative i
don't know what it's like one of those
groups of people contributes positively
to society the other one
do they i mean okay
i have a therapist who i love i mean i i
i get therapy uh at least once a month
often twice a month so i regularly am in
therapy that is a reality that is that
is the truth i've shared on my personal
stream before that i i was on
antidepressants for years and have
struggled with anxiety uh for a long
time in my life now we're getting real
on this show um but yeah i'm a big
believer in um self-care and and
especially when it comes to your mental
health which is sometimes feels like an
easy thing to neglect because you don't
see it and other people don't see it and
they don't know what's going on up here
but mental health is incredibly
important obviously and the fact that
brad is doing everything they can to
give people support who otherwise maybe
wouldn't be able to access the help they
need
we're super excited to be partnered with
them so all right i'm going to do that
professional thing i do where i say hey
thanks to everyone who supported the
show thanks to levy's shirt also levy's
chair also levy's mike all the things
that helped get levy rosman here thank
you to those things
and um
to the chat everyone who tuned in you
didn't get over 2000 so you don't get
the freestyle rap but we will be back
tomorrow for pogchamps 4 presented by
coinbase we'll see you then
[Music]
do
you